hi i'm magnus carlson from norway
i'm the world chess champion uh i've
been that since 2013.
i watched the quinscan bit with uh
great interest and i'm here to take you
through
some of the clips and some of the chess
from the series
the chess stuff is incredibly well well
done
it's also a captivating series in
general
just by the fact that i was watching it
with um
with my girlfriend who who doesn't
actually play chess uh and she found it
uh so captivating and she was the one
who was sort of
pushing for for for us to binge it
rather
than than i was and she she doesn't play
chess so
i don't have that particular memory of
buying a hs board when i was little
the one instance that i do remember of
buying a chessboard
about two and a half years ago where
i simply realized that i don't have a
chessboard at home
and so what i did is that i just
went down to the local
billiards shop which was about 200
meters from where i lived in oslo and i
bought i bought some chessboard
that they had there and um they were
obviously pretty surprised that i
i i needed that
are you sure you want to do this i'm
sure we don't have a women's section
especially uh in places where there
haven't been
too much history of of women playing
playing chess there is
certainly um a tendency for women not to
feel
feel all that all that welcome and
it's it's been male dominated for
for so long and i think a lot of men
like want to want to keep it um keep it
that way
girls are just excite as excited about
chance and just as good at just as boys
the imbalance um comes
partly it comes a bit later and it's
probably also more of a case of of um
parents pushing boys more into chess
than
than maybe parents of girls don't want
to
push them into chess because they they
they think that this will not be an
environment that is
that is good for for their child so i
think
there is definitely a lot to
to work on there but i think
that in principle there
sort of the preconditions should be
should be very
very equal but unfortunately it has it
has not happened
that way uh at all i understand
the sort of skepticism in that
you can't just waltz and tell them
you've never played
a rated game like you don't have any
rating
and you expect to beat them all like
male or female that
would sound ludicrous coming from from
anyone
yeah i think telling her um
there's no women section is um
uncalled for like it's like you're here
you should be treated like
um like anybody
this is definitely the case for for most
tournaments uh
still that they're held in fairly
low profile locations i think chess
definitely a house has a way to
uh to go there uh in the way it's being
uh it's being presented
highest rated players in the whole
[ __ ] country
and yet here we are in some second-rate
university playing on
cheap plastic boards with cheap plastic
pieces
certainly i sort of new world has opened
up
um in terms of um
in terms of uh online series online
chess
the only thing i would be worried about
long term uh
is the future of uh sort of uh classical
chess the the one that
um beth harmon is is playing and that
has been
considered the most prestigious
um where where you play play games over
over several hours
because online people don't really
practice for
for these very long games
so long term um we might be
sort of raising a generation of players
who are much more used to playing speed
chess than the slower chess and
for the future of the game i'm not um
i'm not quite sure how how that will
will pan out but i think overall
justice done has done well um in these
very difficult
circumstances instead of them
i i cannot stress that enough that
i love the way that she respects the
game
she never stops studying she never stops
learning she never stops thinking that
she she can do
better i'm somebody who has never
been great at dealing with uh
with defeats if you take a survey of the
best player
to ask them who the worst loser is my
name is gonna
come up from my own experience along the
time of my career um there definitely
have been
opponents that i um
that i i struggle with uh and i would
say that
the best example is um anand who used to
be
world champion between 2007 and 2013.
so when i started out playing uh at
at the top level uh i struggled a lot
against him
it's very very relatable um the
despair she feels towards the end of the
game
where you know you've been outplayed
uh you know there are no
chances you just um
you're you're just desperately looking
for something anything
any any chance that you can you can
possibly
find whenever you lose like
you start questioning
everything basically is
it's really so so unpleasant
uh it's such an unpleasant feeling to to
lose especially like if
um if you feel like you made mistakes
that you could have
you could have avoided um for me
personally i just try
to channel that anger into into the next
game
i do like the fact for her that losing
is not normal it's not something that
just happens like you you accept it and
then you move
on when you lose you have to make sure
that
it doesn't happen again because it's
it's it's an awful feeling
and the motivation has to be to avoid
feeling that again
don't tell um mr scheible is certainly
an important
mentor but
most of all i think he was just
encouraging her to
to study and that she would um
which she would be the the best teacher
herself my father taught me the rules
and uh as i progressed he
certainly taught me taught me a bit
although still mostly i was studying on
my own
but later on we were at the tournament
and we were going through one of my
games
and my father made a comment
about one of my moves he suggested
something else instead
and one experienced player there
he um he he was just passing by
he just told my father that what he was
teaching me was wrong
my father was kind of spooked by by by
this
and after that he pretty much just uh
left it all left it up to me he felt
that it was much better
that i figured out on my own then he
will
then he give me poor advice the truth of
a child
you're astounding
[Music]
i hope you guys uh enjoyed the clips
and uh me talking about it hopefully
you are more ready now than ever to go
out
beating your friends or whoever you are
playing at
chess so take care and enjoy the game